it's busy in Frankfurt's commercial
district the stores are doing brisk
business and this man's clients are also
in a spending mood hui Chows law firm
closes deals for Chinese investors
buying German companies he told us why
they've been shopping so much this year
10 billion euros in the first half of
2016 alone a new record the affiliate
industry bhai has in many different
sectors of Industry are very interesting
for Chinese investors there have been a
large number of buyouts this year at top
dollar in areas like automation plant
engineering and robot technology I'm
knocking power robot technology we Chow
and his 60 colleagues draw up contracts
in a skyscraper in Germany's banking
capital in ten years China wants to have
a leading position in a wide range of
sectors the government has issued calls
to keep funding at home and focus
investment abroad state and private
investors are targeting big names and
even global leaders like cuca a German
manufacturer of industrial robots in
2016 the Chinese group media bought 95%
of cuca shares for four and a half
billion euros this German flagship
company was relinquished to the Chinese
but where did the money come from this
posture to their strategy it's all part
of the Chinese government's strategy
medea probably got support from the
Chinese government we don't know but we
assume so gift
medea now ranks among the top global
groups fear media is this nitration oh I
know this is also a huge leap forward in
terms of media's portfolio until now
they only made household appliances like
refrigerators and microwaves now they're
suddenly dealing in robotics robotic
Chinese state-owned groups are buying
privately owned German companies German
companies
however aren't allowed to acquire
Chinese companies they're usually
obliged to create a joint venture with
the Chinese partner certainly in the
automobile and insurance sectors and
taking over companies related to rare
earth products or armaments is strictly
forbidden
cows mafia is a munich-based company and
the global leader in injection moulding
machines this year a buyer from Asia
paid around a billion euros to acquire
the firm the machines here make rubber
tires and plastic panels for the
automobile industry as well as plastic
cups the quality is always very high of
the 4,500 employees 800 are engineers
this know-how is important to the
Chinese says calcifies Managing Director
China is moving away from cheap mass
production towards high quality and
price sensitive products and it needs
help to make this transition because
they don't have the right expertise
transform our own hands to become by
really a company like krauss-maffei is a
premium manufacturer so it can help the
Chinese with the change of products from
ASEAN hints of a company back in
Frankfurt the sale of another market
later Extron to a half state-owned
Chinese consortium was recently haunted
by the German Ministry for Economic
Affairs and US President Barack Obama
the reason Extron has a factory in the
US and it manufactures machines that
produce semiconductors the Chinese could
use this technology for military
purposes trade between China and the
West is often subject to uncertainty
she is easy for when they are caught
imagine if coca had been acquired by an
American company across Maathai were
bought by a French company the
likelihood of any one in Germany having
misgivings about it would have been very
minimal yet in Russia I'm Malcolm
McConnell and for him the lucrative
contract business as an attorney has
only just begun because he doesn't
believe that the Germans will allow the
dispute to escalate the sale of their
products in China is simply too
important
[Music]